a good friend of yours Elijah Wood and
your co-star Lord of the Rings was here
recently you mentioned he mentions you a
lot when I talked to him we're good buds
you guys you made the movies together
and then you hang out now oh yeah yeah
yeah we a large and I have very similar
interests we both film obsessives music
obsessives we like doing the same stuff
we you know we we just enjoyed hanging
out together unfortunately well I guess
mostly because he's so busy I don't get
seen as much as I'd like because I'm in
different places in the he's in
different places what kind of stuff do
you like what are your shared interests
specifically we play a lot of board
games play lost Scrabble together we
walked no question it's gonna get way
worse now because we get involved in
building a Lego Millennium Falcon
together are you really this is a this
is something you've pledged to do
together yeah yeah because we're both
Star Wars finance I think Star was
probably the reason why I became an
actor and I like Lego I became more and
more interested in Lego as I found out
that Lord the Rings was gonna be Lego
characters and then the Millennium
Falcon is the ultimate Lego thing that
you can build third Star Wars so we're
gonna hang out and we're gonna build the
Millennium Falcon I mean come on
[Applause]
you know that I mean that you're gonna
have to block up some time to do that
you know how many pieces it is it means
it's thousands a piece in fact and I'm
not kidding about this we have a writer
on our show Andre do Boucher who has
built the Millennium Falcon yes
I'm not kidding this is not a bit or
anything he's built it and I asked him I
knew you were going to talk about this
Andre would you come out here for a
second beautiful oh that is great
that's not can I ask you a question is
Andre yeah is there a Smuggler's escape
hatched built into the Millennium Falcon
not on this little thing it's not yeah
it needs to trick that much inside of it
it's just Legos now how long did this
take how long did this take you to build
Andre about a month a month
oh and what was it was it hard it was
pretty hard okay okay alright thank you
very much Andre do Bechet everybody
[Music]
Wow that's that's you still want to do
it that's not gonna work out because we
gave us stuff about six hours lots of
complim you could get like hundreds of
friends to help you yeah we could do
that
our friends tell me so you're really
gonna do that and you guys also do box
oh well this happened because Elijah and
I attended a Film Festival and the film
that was kind of the the major film that
they were showing at this festival was
it was a documentary called knuckle
about an Irish bare-knuckle fighter yeah
because of that they had some kind of
boxing matches occurring and it was the
guy who played the actual Ben achill
fire fighting the guy ran the festival
so that wasn't gonna be a real fight and
then he had a boy fighting a girl so
that wasn't gonna be a real real fight
maybe had like a 6-4-3 guy find a very
small guy and me and Elijah so me and
Elijah said well let's just fine and
that's what we did we like put on gloves
and you really go at it yeah we pawn
huge pink gloves and we not the hell
have each other I think we have a clip
of YouTube beating on each other or one
of you beating sweetie yeah let's take a
look at this
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
two observations one is you seem to be
getting the much better of the fight you
are really wailing away on Elijah he
annoyed me and the second thing is it
would be so funny if you guys wore the
giant Hobbit five you know mine you
could see your repaired fee if you had
the giant feet yeah we should have done
that my feet are pretty pink I'm not the
you know toilets going 125 seven but I
got like sighs ten feet so you know they
said about big theory I really don't big
socks okay
[Laughter]